- [Narrator] There's a
lot of international mail
that flows to a small
nation in Western Africa.
The mail is addressed to an address
that should be right here
along this main street.
But I asked my friends to
go there and check it out,
and he didn't find anything.
- I've been looking for 80 Broad Street.
I'm gonna say that 80
Broad Street doesn't exist.
- [Narrator] Instead, the mail
that is addressed to go here
is actually brought to a building
down the road, right here.
- Right here,
this building is where all
LISCR bills are forwarded,
from the building that doesn't
exist on 80 Broad Street.
- [Narrator] From there,
the mail is scanned
and sent electronically
thousands of miles away
to a nondescript office building
outside of Washington, DC,
it's actually right near my
house in Northern Virginia.
- Henry check out this random building.
Does this building looks
super boring to you?
- Ooh.
- This building is right near our house.
I guess I expected something
a little bit more interesting.
- [Narrator] This process
is a part of a secretive web
of corporate secrecy.
It's a web that is built off
of years of strange connections
between the United States
and the country of Liberia,
a nation invented by a group
of Americans here in Virginia.
This is how the US stashed its secrets
off the coast of West Africa.
- In this building,
there is a bunch of mail that comes from
a little country in West Africa,
and it gets sent to this
building near our house.
Does that seem kind of weird to you?
- Yes, what do they do with it?
(chuckles)
- That's what I wanna figure out here.
So, let's say I wanna start
an international corporation
and start doing business abroad.
I live here in the United States,
so naturally I would wanna
start my company here in the US,
but when I asked the
internet how to do this,
I get a bunch of ads that look like this.
Even though my office would be here
in Washington, DC in the United States,
the internet is telling me that on paper,
I should set up my corporation
in one of these random,
small countries around the world.
Places like the British
Virgin islands, or Mauritius,
or Belize, Gibraltar, Malta,
the Seychelles Islands,
wait, the Seychelles like
that tiny Island nation
in the middle of the Indian ocean,
that has like less than a
hundred thousand people.
It's like 40 hours of flying to get there,
why would I wanna set up my
business in the Seychelles?
(upbeat music)
Here's why.
If I set up my corporation on paper,
in the British Virgin
islands or the Seychelles,
suddenly I actually don't
have to pay very much taxes,
if any at all.
My new corporation now won't have
to actually obey any of the corporate laws
here in the United States,
which require you to publish
all sorts of information
about your finances,
about your corporation
to the public record.
If my corporation is in the Seychelles,
I don't have to do any of that,
this is actually starting
to seem like a pretty attractive option.
These tiny nations have set up their laws
to attract big corporations
for this very purpose,
to set up on paper in their country,
so that the government can
make a little bit of money
off of the little taxes they receive
and any of the registration fees and dues.
And it's not just corporations,
the same concept applies
to shipping vessels.
These are big barges that
make our world economy run,
and they spend most of their time in water
that belongs to no country,
and yet they still have
to follow the rules
of the country, whose flag they fly,
where they're registered.
And so if you register to a
country that has very low taxes,
and no laws around how you need
to treat your employees on the boat,
and what safety regulations
you need to follow,
then those are the
rules you need to follow
when you're out on the high sea.
So, the modern global economy turns out
to be a race to the bottom.
Corporations and shipping vessels,
registering themselves to
whatever country will give them
the least amount of
accountability and transparency,
we call these havens,
tax havens or shelters.
And this isn't just like
shady criminal corporations,
most corporations that you
interact with on a daily basis,
have loads of subsidiaries
in far away tax havens,
that they have set up
to escape transparency and accountability.
(low tempo music)
- Okay, but back to me
and my corporation that I
theoretically want to sign up,
If I wanna set up in the Seychelles
or the British Virgin islands,
this is actually kind of complicated,
how do I navigate all the
laws and the paperwork?
Ask the internet.
And when I asked the internet,
I get a bunch of ads.
These are ads of companies
who are dedicated
to helping corporations set up
in these offshore jurisdictions
and these tax havens.
So, if I wanna set up in
the British Virgin islands,
I could choose a bunch
of different companies
to help me get that paperwork done.
And then while I actually do my business
back here in Washington, DC,
they help manage all the
taxes and the requirements,
and all the little things I need to do
to upkeep my little facade
of having a company in this place,
even though I actually don't.
Okay, so here's where this gets weird,
we're talking about tax havens
and offshore jurisdictions
and all this stuff, let's
get back to Liberia,
which Liberia is one of these tax havens.
It's a place that has structured its laws
to attract foreign corporations
and shipping vessels,
to register with them so that
they can make a little money
off of those dues and taxes.
- [Narrator] When I go to start
my corporation in Liberia,
I don't get a bunch of ads for middlemen
who wanna help me set up my
new Liberian corporation,
instead I'm funneled to
one company, this one,
and this company boasts that
it has the exclusive right
to handle all companies
that wanna register
their corporation or ship in Liberia.
This is the company whose
building is near my house.
And on the surface, it just
looks like another middleman,
paper pusher, super boring,
but you peek under the surface
and there's something
way bigger going on here.
Not just a corporation
running away from taxes
and accountability,
but instead this is a symbol
of how the US projects its
power in the 21st century,
and how it uses other
countries to hide its secrets.
(dramatic music)
- Quick pause for a second.
This story is crazy and it's
about to get even more crazy.
The whole reason I'm going
down this rabbit hole,
that I started to look
into this Liberia thing,
is because of a phone call I had.
I was driving North up to
Massachusetts a couple months ago,
many of you may have seen
the videos from that trip,
and it was on the phone with
my friend Ben over at Fully,
Fully is the company who makes my desk
and the chair I'm sitting on.
Ben and I got chatting.
I just announced that
I report was canceled,
and I was sort of moving
on to new projects,
and he was like, what
stories do you want to make?
And like, can we support your stories?
I was like, yes,
but like anything that has to do
with like the global economy,
which is something I'm
sort of interested in.
I'm gonna go deep and I'm
gonna uncover crazy stuff,
and like your company does
business in the global economy,
and he was like, do it.
I wanna see like what
storytelling you can do
and we wanna support that.
For context here of Fully is a B Corp.
A B Corp is a type of corporation
that isn't just the standard
profit seeking company,
instead they make major
efforts to be transparent,
to be socially impactful
in a positive way,
to be accountable and to be sustainable,
that's rare, that's a rare thing.
Fully does not claim to be perfect,
all they say is that they're
making a major effort,
to be the type of corporation
that leaves a positive impact
on the people who use the product,
but also the people who
interact with the production,
and to leave a positive impact
on the globe while doing so.
And that's why they're
supporting this video today,
is because they care
about this sort of thing,
and they want to always
be pushing the limit
on how we think about business,
and how we think about the impact
of corporations in the world.
And I respect that,
that is so rare among
companies these days,
and so I love Fully for that reason,
oh, and they make amazing products,
like that's also a giant part of this.
So my desk, a lot of the stuff
in our studio is Fully stuff.
They sell really high quality
products, desks, and chairs,
and all sorts of products
that make you more active,
and just improve your
relationship with work.
They don't want you to buy these products
unless you actually need them.
But there's a lot of
people these days who tend
to need a new work from home set up,
given the times we're in,
and so they are running
a sale on their site
for the whole month of November,
which is a few days left in that sale.
These are not just your standard desks,
these are an investment in a product
that will last you a very long time.
They're solid, they're well-built.
Go onto the Fully site,
check out their products,
see if there's anything there
that you need right now.
But the major here is Fully
wants you to be thoughtful
about the stuff that you buy,
knowing that it's often a
part of a much larger system.
Thank you Fully for supporting this video.
Let's get back to the story of Liberia
and what the heck is happening in Liberia,
it gets pretty nuts from here.
(upbeat music)
What's the deal?
Why does this one random
building in Virginia,
run a network of corporate secrecy
in the country of Liberia?
Like it's so weird,
and as soon as you start to
go down this rabbit hole,
it just gets weirder.
And the short answer here is that
the United States of
America literally invented
the country of Liberia.
Back in the 1800s here
in the United States,
the biggest, most important
debate was over slavery.
This issue led the country
to almost imploding on itself
in a bloody civil war.
During this debate,
there emerged three major
camps with the slavery issue.
One where the abolitionists,
the people who were like,
dude, this is wrong,
let's reform our country
to be done with this
terrible thing we've done.
And then of course there were the people
on the pro-slavery side,
who were often had a financial incentive
to keep slavery alive
with their plantations
and their businesses.
But then there was this
third camp in the middle,
who were on paper against slavery.
They wanted to get rid of
slavery, it was a bad thing,
but they didn't really want
the freed black Americans
to integrate into American society.
As this debate, raged on,
there were some Americans here in Virginia
who came up with a solution.
What if we gave the option
to enslaved people who had been freed,
to go to Africa where
their ancestors came from?
We could ship them back.
We could buy a piece of land
and they would all flock
to the boats to go back to
Africa was the thinking here.
The quasi abolitionists
kind of liked this,
'cause they're like, Oh yeah,
we can get the moral buzz
out of being against slavery,
but we don't have to deal with
the complicated consequences
of our actions to reintegrate
these people into our society.
And then of course the
slave owners liked this too,
because it meant that
any freed black Americans
could be shipped away,
so they wouldn't foment
rebellion among those enslaved
people who were still
working on plantations.
So, there was this strange alignment
between these quasi abolitionists
and these slave owners,
and they started their own organization.
- [Narrator] So, this organization
that was based here in Virginia,
bought a piece of land in Western Africa,
with money from their supporters
and from the US government.
And they started sending
ships full of black people
to this land to create a
settlement that they called Liberia
or land of the free.
They named the Capital Monrovia,
after president James Monroe,
who was a fierce supporter of this effort
to send away free black Americans.
- Okay, so at this point,
I'm sure you're kind of like,
wait a minute, what was this curve ball?
We went from talking about
the Seychelles and tax havens,
to talking about how a bunch of Virginians
started sending freed black Americans
to a piece of land in
Africa that they bought,
and this is where these two come together.
Soon, the Liberians declare independence.
Liberian locals,
the ones who had come
from the United States,
that started to take power
and actually be the
leaders of the country.
They actually started to
enact slavery of their own
in their society,
just like they had seen
in the United States.
But behind the scenes of all of this,
the US political interests
that started this whole thing remained.
They had an actual building there
and they were actually calling the shots.
So Liberia was independent on paper,
but in reality the US had
as much influence as ever,
in their little colony in Africa.
And that influence became really useful
a hundred years later.
(upbeat music)
So it's a hundred years later,
the US just got out of world war II
and you have this guy,
this guy was the secretary
of state for the US,
which is like a foreign minister.
He became a US representative at the UN,
and he was out on a diplomatic tour
that brought him to Liberia.
While in Liberia, this
little African nation
that was created by the United States,
and still had deep ties
to the United States,
he looked at the deep sea port
that the US had created
during world war II,
and his wheels started turning.
He returned to the United States
and quickly stepped down
from his role as a diplomat.
Harry Truman like really wanted him
to stick around as a diplomat,
but he had actually a very
strong reason to leave.
Truman said that he had
an earnest insistence
to go do his own thing.
This guy was a diplomat, but
he was also a businessman,
and what he saw during
his visit to Liberia,
revealed a business opportunity
that he just could not leave on the table.
So over the next year,
this ex secretary of state
started scheming with
the Liberian government.
And in September, 1947,
he came out and announced that
he a private American citizen
had made a deal with
the Liberian government.
He created a company,
an American based company,
based here in Virginia,
that was to be the exclusive middleman
between any international corporation
and the government of Liberia.
Basically,
if anyone wanted to set up
their corporation in Liberia,
they would have to go through
this guy and his new company.
He helped the Liberian
government craft laws
that would make it very attractive,
for people to put the
Liberian flag on their ship
or on their company, and
over the next few years,
this gained major traction.
At this time, any shipping
vessel that had the American flag
or the Soviet flag,
would be subject to a
bunch of trade barriers,
that were starting to go up as
a part of this like cold war
between the US and the Soviets.
This ex secretary of
state and his new company,
would go around and say,
"Hey, put the Liberian flag
on your ship,
and now you can trade with
whoever the hell you want."
The Liberian registry exploded,
and now you had ships
flying the Liberian flag,
not having to pay barely any taxes,
and not having to obey any
laws from the United States,
and being able to trade
with whomever they want,
because Liberia was officially
neutral in the cold war.
The Liberian registry was
born and it was the thriving.
(upbeat music)
So in recent decades,
the number of ships that
register under the Liberian flag,
who never stepped foot
in Liberia by the way,
but have their flag on
their ship has grown.
And it has become the
second most common flag
on international ships in the
world, only second to Panama.
Meanwhile, the company here in Virginia,
who has a monopoly over this
registry is getting super rich,
and they're giving some of those riches
to the Liberian government.
But what the librarian
government does with that money
is actually, probably
the ugliest underbelly
of this whole story.
(upbeat music)
So by the late 90s this
company's doing great,
Liberia is taking in a bunch of money
from all of the ships
registering under their flag,
but then this guy, Charles
Taylor becomes the president.
- How can I help you on
Liberian shipping registries?
It's a long time since
I've been looking at them.
- What has the registry allowed
the government of Liberia
to do that, that it wouldn't
be able to do otherwise?
- It was one of the most consistent,
dependable sources of revenue
for the Liberian government.
That was important,
particularly in the Charles Taylor period
when it was civil war in Liberia,
and there were no other
sources of revenue.
It was a war economy.
- He starts taking the
money that's coming in
from all these ship and
corporation registries,
but not just to fight these wars,
he goes on to commit some
of the most egregious
crimes the world has ever seen.
- I was the one myself
that investigated the shipping registry.
We found, documented, exposed
that the shipping registry,
that its revenues were being
diverted to purchase arms
and ammunition in
violation of UN sanctions.
(upbeat music)
- And yet corporations and ships
that fly the Liberian flag,
don't even have to think about this stuff.
They don't step foot in Liberia.
They've never met Charles
Taylor or any of his people,
they just go about doing their thing
and doing all of their business
through a nondescript
office, right near my house,
where a company is getting very rich
using Liberia as the facade,
but really everything
is happening right here.
The money is being made right here,
and a little bit of that
is being sent to Liberia,
and Liberia is using it
to do terrible things.
Charles Taylor eventually goes
to the International Court of Justice
and gets indicted on a million
really horrible counts,
goes to jail for the rest of his life.
But the registry that helped
fund his horrible rise remains,
and remains as a mechanism
for helping many corporations
around the world,
hide their secrets and
evade accountability.
And this connection between
these two unlikely places,
retains a similar purpose
as its original one.
Way back in the 1800s,
when with the support
of the US government,
private interests sent away their secrets
and their guilt to a far away place.
And that hasn't really stopped happening,
today with the blessing
of the US government,
corporations continue
to deposit their secrets
in this same far away place,
far away from any real accountability.
Thank you all for watching this video,
this is the type of video
that I wanna do more of.
A video like this takes longer,
it takes more time because
it's a lot more research,
it's more interviews,
and actually diving way
deeper into these stories
than than the typical explainer
you see on this channel.
And that's what I wanna
do starting in 2021,
I wanna start doing
more stories like this.
My patrons make that possible.
And brands like Fully who
care about this sort of thing,
make that possible as well.
So, I am hoping that more
and more we'll be able
to do deep dive stories like this.
And then when travel opens up,
I wanna be able to travel
and go do deep dive stuff,
like I used to do it at box.
So thank you all for watching,
and I've got some more good stuff coming,
and I hope you are having
a wonderful November.
I'll see you soon.